-Welcome back to the show
in person.
-Thank you! I know!
-I mean...
-We're back.
-You're back in New York City.
-Here we are.
-This is your hometown.
-This is it.
-How's it feel?
-Feels great.
-It does, right?
-It feels amazing.
-I wanted to ask you because
tonight's a big show for us.
We have -- obviously, you're on.
But I mean, we have, the Olympic
opening ceremonies was tonight
and I heard that you were almost
in an Olympic commercial once.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is that true?
-Yes.
Well, I was in
an Olympic commercial.
-You were?
-I don't think it aired.
Because I might -- I --
[ Laughs ]
Okay, so here's the story.
The story is I went in
to audition
and you know, when you first
start auditioning,
I went in as a dancer
and kind of like whatever.
And they were like,
"Okay, can you dance?"
I danced and then I talked
and I read the copy
and I did the things,
and then they were like,
"By the way" -- I'm walking out
and I'm like, I nailed this.
I killed this.
-I got this.
I was great today.
Today was my day.
-Yes, exactly.
-I'm walking out and I'm like,
"Okay, bye, thank you.
Thank you so much. Thank you."
And I walk out
and the guy says to me,
right before I leave, he goes,
"Hey, by the way,
can you do trampoline?"
And I go, "Yeah."
And I walk out,
thinking nothing of it.
-Sure. Yeah.
-Can I do a trampoline?
Are you kidding me?
-I get there and I do
all the things, I dance, I sing,
and then they bring out this
trampoline and they're like,
"Okay!"
-"Let's see what you got."
-"Do it!"
And I was like...okay.
They're like, "You know, you do
the flips and the things."
And I was like, "Sure,
I'll do the trampoline."
I get up there and I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
That was it.
That's all I had.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cut to c--
Is that all she does?
Did she do the trampoline?
-I did this!
I did this, I jumped,
and I did some of this.
-You posed.
-It was awful.
-That's not doing trampoline.
-And they were like, "You said
you could do trampoline."
And I said, "No, I..."
-I'm sorry.
-I did, but I didn't know
what you meant.
-How's the fam?
-Everybody's good.
-Two teenagers.
-I know.
-Wow, is that wild.
-I know, does anybody else
have teenagers right now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-It's interesting, right?
-It is. It is.
You know, they go from like
being these babies,
and then when they turn
like 11 1/2, 12,
they become like adult people
in a little body.
-I know, I know.
I'm like -- every second,
I love hanging out with my kids
because I just don't want you
to grow up, but I do.
-What they do is
that they need to, like,
distance themselves a little.
You know, it's my life.
I have my own identity.
I am who I am, this is what
I feel about the world.
This is what I think.
And, you know, it's like,
Oh, my God, and I'm like,
"Baby, you want to sit
on my lap?"
[ Both laugh ]
-No, I don't now.
I'm a teenager. Not at all.
-Mom, stop. Stop touching me.
-I'll tell you
who is here tonight --
your mom is here.
-Who also likes me
to still sit on her lap.
-Lupe is here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Mom.
-Hi, beautiful.
Oh, my god, she is
the prettiest, the coolest.
Is that --
Is that where you get
your drive? Is that --
-From my mom?
-Yeah.
-Where do you think?
-I think I get my --
like, my personality
from my mom, a little bit.
And you know, both my mom
and dad worked really hard.
-Yeah.
-So I definitely --
-I don't know anyone
that works as hard as you.
-I know. I don't know
what's wrong with me.
I'm not well.
-No, you are unbelievable.
But I've known you
since "Saturday Night Live,"
but I've seen in every --
-I know.
-Every aspect,
and you're just there
and you're just mentally
in the game and you're like,
"Yeah, cool. What's up?
We'll do that," blah blah.
-What's next? Let's do it!
-"We'll do this. What's next?"
-I go...
-This is fun!
-But like, "Marry Me."
You go, "Great,
I'm in this movie."
That's enough for me.
-I mean, I grew up in the Bronx.
My mom'll tell you,
we grew up in the Bronx.
We really didn't have a lot.
You know,
this is a dream come true.
Everything I do,
every single day,
I feel so incredibly blessed.
I feel so lucky to be doing
what I'm doing.
I always wanted to sing.
I always wanted to dance.
My mother loved musicals,
you know,
she showed me them from
when I was very, very little,
and I just had all these dreams
of like doing that.
And so now I'm doing it.
So why not do it all the time?
I'll do it all the time.
You got it. Everybody knows.
-Yeah, yeah. But I mean...
-You guys -- The Roots want
to play all the time.
-Yeah.
-All they want to do is play.
Every chance you get
to pick up a guitar,
whether you're playing or not,
whether you're at work,
you're doing what you love.
-You just want to do, like...
Just play.
-Yeah. You know that.
-I know, but you also did
the soundtrack to this.
-I did.
-You and Maluma are all over --
this is all you.
And this is out now.
The movie comes out next week.
-Yes! Look at it!
Yay!
-Ah, there you go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It never gets old for me.
Yes, this was actually
the first time
since I did the movie "Selena"
where I actually got to --
I didn't sing
in the movie "Selena."
That was Selena's voice.
-Yeah.
-So this is the first time
I got to, like, sing,
make an album for a film.
It is like joining
my two worlds together.
I also got to play a character
who was, you know,
a lot like myself.
You know,
she's in the spotlight,
personal life, public life,
trying to make it all work.
You know,
failing miserably at times.
You know what I mean?
Doing all the things.
But it's a really,
really great kind of look
behind the behind the scenes.
-Yeah, I remember the last time
you were here with Maluma.
-Yes.
-You actually had a scene
in the movie
where you're supposed
to be at a concert.
You guys are doing your famous
duet in character.
-Yeah.
-And instead of re-creating
a fake concert
on a movie set somewhere,
you crashed Maluma's --
-Oh, I did. We did.
-...Maluma's concert.
-Yes, he was having like two
nights at Madison Square Garden.
And of course,
the producer in me is like,
"We can take advantage of that."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, yeah.
It's like, yeah.
Alright, he's already got --
-We have a scene, a big scene
in an arena.
Why don't we do it
at your concert?
And he was like, "Okay..."
-Yeah.
-How'd that feel?
People must have went bonkers --
-It was amazing.
-...when you walked out.
-It was amazing, yeah.
I came up out of the floor
dressed like the character
in the movie,
and this scene is in the movie.
And they just didn't expect me
to come out at his concert.
I've never been out
at one of his concerts.
And the crowd went wild,
and we got it all on film
and we sang together.
And it was -- it was awesome.
-And I will say the whole --
you're on the whole soundtrack,
is you and Maluma.
I mean, this thing is --
it's awesome.
-Yeah, it's not like
a Jennifer Lopez J.Lo album
or even a Maluma album.
It's a Kat and Bastian album.
These are songs that I really
picked for the characters
and that really kind of like
further along the story,
just like any good musical.
-Yeah.
-And it really tells
the love story,
the journey of, you know,
kind of finding your true love.
-I want to talk about "Marry Me"
when we come back.
More with Jennifer Lopez
Come on!